Chevrolet's Corvette Stingray still has
a dedicated cult following in the early
1960 Chevy one of America's big four set
out to give establish sports car makers
like Jaguar and Maserati a run for their
money the new Corvettes design reflected
the typical sports car styling of the
time a long engine compartment with a
snappy fastback the shape character and
image of this automotive legend were
American through and through until the
arrival of the Dodge Viper in 1992 the
Corvette was the only true sports car
made entirely in the USA under the hood
of course the Stingray had a v8 packing
250 horsepower in the basic version an
optional extra was a 4-speed stick shift
which was a usual option for an American
car
the Stingray was also the first Corvette
to offer two different body styles a
coupe 8 and a convertible Chevrolet
fitted successive models of the Stingray
with bigger and bigger engines the v8
big-block version sported a businesslike
but fake air scoop on the hood
throughout its five-year run the
stingrays basic form remained almost
unchanged that was also unusual in 1960s
America where new models appeared every
year time now for a trip back in time
the Corvette appeared a decade before
the Stingray hit showrooms Chevrolet
unveiled the first model now known as
the c12 an admiring public at the
General Motors Motorama in 1953
Chevrolet engineer at race car driver
Zora arkus-duntov is known as the father
of the Corvette he mounted a lean
two-seater fiberglass body on a robust
box frame a concept that has survived to
the current generation of Corvettes the
Corvette didn't get its famous v8 engine
till 1956 after that marriage the street
cruiser was transformed into a serious
sports car in 1960 a Corvette team
entered the LeMond 24 hour race against
the European competition taking 8th
place overall but first in its class it
was a good showing for the new kid on
the block
by the early 60s the original Corvette
was beginning to look past at sell by
date the design department kicked around
various ideas until head designer Bill
Mitchell got inspiration for the first
Corvette Coupe a from an actual stingray
the new stingray was even sporty-er
leaner and meaner
47 year-old engineer Oliver leap is a
Corvette fan body and soul he collects
everything connected with this
automotive icon his impressive
collection includes Corvettes from 1964
to 1996 but his favorite is the c2 the
Stingray model built from 1963 to 67
whenever he finds some time in his busy
schedule he takes one of his treasures
out for a spin
he says he dreamt of Corvettes even as a
child he saw one as a small boy and
immediately fell in love with it
eventually he began collecting them
whenever he could he admits it's a
typical male dream
he explains that in American car
collector circles the c2 is the USA's
answer to the Porsche it handles very
well in comparison to its contemporaries
and relative to other vintage classic
sports cars it's still affordable over
tribe have his blue 65 coupe a
completely restored and customized to
his own specifications in the United
States but Corvette fan though he is he
says the performance of the big-block v8
is only just enough
American car fans call a Corvette like
Oliver's a sleeper that means it has
lots of power under the hood but
everything else is like the original
nowadays a stingray in good condition
can run a good 50 thousand euros the
most sought-after models are the big
blocks and split-window coupe A's
the best place to find one ethanol is in
the United States